i didn't think it would happen that
quickly like last year
i had time to get out before we over
topped
but yeah this time that didn't happen
for the residents of bewdley
it has happened all over again gossip to
be honest
this took me years and years to buy a
house i'll buy one in a town i love
and it's flooded twice in two years
sorry sorry i know it's very difficult
and i suppose it's been made all the
worse given the year that
it's been right yeah
honestly boris gets his
the permanent buried and
what impact does it have on your lives
and your neighbors lives
by not getting it done
stress levels through the roof
i'm gonna have nowhere to live for about
three or four months while they fix it
but i'm in with with a comb it's just
going to delay everything
intense rainfall on saturated ground
meant these temporary barriers simply
couldn't hold back the seven
some of these residents had only moved
back into their houses
in the last couple of months new carpets
new furniture
all of it destroyed again they remember
the prime minister being stood here
saying that he would get
beautifully done but yet again the
defenses have failed
the west side of the seven imbuedly has
a permanent defense
which held but the east side is still
waiting for an answer
the kinds of solutions that we're
looking at are similar to what we've got
on
the other side maybe maybe some kind of
wall with glass panels where we've used
elsewhere
flood gates that can be shut that will
give some more permanence
but there's a number of different
options that we're looking at there
and until we've got to the place where
we understand what that technical
feasibility is it would be wrong for me
to tell you exactly what the solution is
last june the government announced a 5
billion pound plan to help
tackle flooding while the focus has been
on
kovid 19 the residents here want action
if mr johnson's watching this now he's
please could you get things moving
because we i don't think we could stand
much more of the
devastation that goes on for now
just like 11 months ago the cleanup
starts
all over again dan whitehead's sky news
in bewdley worcestershire